you say you're very reliant on makeup I
mean yeah I only may wear makeup for the
show and then go out and and if it's a
guy I'm just like look and of course
I've been married forever and I just
think no one's no one's worried about
this yep there it is what are you gonna
do but yeah yeah bake but your say you
put a lot of work into it I can't leave
the house without it because if let's
say I go to the bank I don't go to the
bank but like let's say I throw on
contour just a direct deposit a cheque
in my living room you know like I take a
picture just in case there's a break-in
and I have like a vibe with my assailant
all the time just in case that I meet
the man that I'm meant to be with in
like I just don't trust that if a man
that I meant to be with sees me without
makeup he's gonna look at me and go like
that's a man I'm not meant to be with
because wait you think you look like a
man without makeup
Coenen I know I look like a man without
makeup I've been saying this for years
and people go no you're beautiful I'm
like no I'm a hot dude like I I'm a
better-looking guy almost and then it
was proven to me this is true okay I'm I
did this new show on Netflix called
historical roast that's coming out next
year
Jeff Ross created it it's like comedians
dressing up as dead celebrities and then
roasting each other in heaven
Jeff Ross asked me to do it he asked me
he goes do you wanna play Princess Diana
and I'm like uh yeah as a three year old
blonde lady who loves Blazers like sign
me up that's like my tree what an iconic
person to get to play yeah of course
practicing I was getting into character
I was practicing the accent I was
dabbling in bulimia like I was really
Daniel day-lewis in it and then he then
I find out so I get the offer sent to me
I agree to it and and then in the fine
print it's like for the role of Kurt
Cobain and I was like switched it why'd
they switch it
he was just like we thought it'd be
funnier yeah
apparently it's a prank show because I
was I was I was like okay I can play a
dude so I show up to set and I'm like
all right like I'm gonna get into this
and I'm I go to hair and makeup and I'm
like I'm ready to be transformed into a
man and they throw in a wig and I'm like
yeah and then I go to makeup and I'm
like I'm ready and they're like you're
good didn't wear any makeup to be a man
they really your face is fine I was like
do you want to put on stubble they're
like we might need to take some away
[Laughter]
really yeah you look good oh I've
referenced that picture for myself